likely I'm not an intellectual I'm apart
good
I have two things well maybe more than
the first thing is the political thing I
come from Poland and you remember this
the beautiful solidarity solidarity
movement who gave who created some new
so a real solidarity among the oppressed
ones and which was a beautiful human
energy in it and it created a democratic
state after 989 which was not
flourishing but building its own future
and relying on law and now some of these
same people from the Solidarity movement
have created a government which is which
denies the achievements of solidarity
and which which goes against the law and
these are the same people it's not
people from the planet Mars
you know Venus and Mars now it's there
from from the same movement so it's a
deeply disturbing thing that some
mechanism of envy of desire of political
ambition push are pushing them to these
ruthless action the good thing is that
there's a very strong resistance we have
the civil society which is not
capitulating so the thing is not over
I'm pessimistic but optimistic as well
but I'm here not as a politician I guess
well as a poet right so and rubber
wanted me to say something about the the
beauty the art and I feel a little bit
like someone coming from from distant
provinces because you talk about power
and politics and poetry has no power at
very few people read poems nowadays and
yet it is a kind of secret power you
know you could define purge as the
revenge of the introverts we we
introverts we have our secret world we
listen to music we reach poems and we
read philosophy we don't create any no
we have no institutions we live outside
institution so I won't help you here
Embree I feel like you know in the
rational literature there was a notion
of a leash neato of yak of an
unnecessary human beings among the
representatives of the Russian
intelligentsia were defined by by
Turgenev and by other writers as none
unnecessary people there's a kind of
self ironic description these people are
not producing anywhere else that later
unfortunately they produce the the
Soviet you know the Soviet system so
that's and their evolution but you know
poetry and art I mean it doesn't make
sense to speak separately about poetry
together with with arts with music
there's kind of as you say a repository
of of some lucidity 30 gives us moments
of lucidity points are different from
storytellers we don't tell stew lyric
poets don't tell stories we react to
moments of lucidity a poem a good poem
is a record of a moment of lucidity it's
there's no story there is no lesson
there's no moral lesson but there's the
lucidity itself is a value because for a
mom and we see better we understand
better and this is what means to be
human
to have these moments of lucidity so
please tell I
let live let boys live I started this
morning with telling you about the drop
of wine in the ocean which can transform
the ocean one drop of wine was published
in the New York in the week right after
9/11 and the Bossip poem it was a poem
by our friend Adam Safi Eskie and many
New Yorkers now know this poem by heart
because it was for them that drop of
wine that transformed the experience and
I've asked Adam to read it for us at the
end of this conference please try to
praise the mutilated world remember
Jones long days and wild strawberries
drops of rose air while the nettles that
methodically overgrow they abandoned
homesteads of exiles you must praise the
mutilated world you watched the stylish
yachts and ships one of them had a long
trade the fourth while salty oblivion
awaited others you've seen the refugees
heading nowhere
you've heard the executioner's saying
joyfully you have to praise the
mutilated world remember the moments
when we were together in a white room
and the curtain flattered returned and
saw to the concert where music flirt you
gathered acorns in the park in autumn
and leaves a deed over the earth scars
praise the mutilated world and the gray
feather afresh lost and the gentle light
that strays and vanishes and returned
[Applause]
you